auch in dieser woche konnten sich die
parteien in berlin nicht auf eine
wahlrechtsreform einigen es bleibt also
beim xxl bundestag dem zweit
vollgestopften parlament der welt nach
china
wahnsinn freunde wirklich 709
abgeordnete sitzen schon drin demnächst
werden es wohl noch mehr aber kommt ist
ja nur geld ist ja nur geld und diese
geplatzte reform ist symptomatisch für
eine regierung im wahlkampfmodus
trotzdem beharrt die groko darauf ihre
politik sei eigentlich super man müsse
sie nur besser verkaufen und genau dafür
für pr arbeit haben sie zuletzt haben
wir festgestellt auch deutlich mehr
investiert etwa das finanzministerium
von 2017 bis 2019 ein plus von 68
prozent oder das verkehrsministerium mit
weniger gestartet das plus dafür umso
höher 202 prozent
202 prozent mehr geld für stars selbst
erstellung wow
wofür wird die zusätzliche kohle denn
verballert für quietscheenten
hh gute idee ja super eingelebt
[Applaus]
es ist ein gutes beispiel
er ist ein gutes beispiel scheuer und
seine pr-abteilung feuern wirklich rund
um die uhr aus allen social media foren
und wenn er wie neulich einen diesel
rückruf verkündet dann gibt es keine
interviews oder pressekonferenzen wie
früher sondern ein internetvideo ohne
lästige nachfragen durch journalisten
übrigens ein echter trend minister
lassen sich im netz kritisch von devoten
mitarbeitern interview der stars war ein
langer langer tag heute aber es war ein
guter oder wir haben's geschafft
und da 2021 wird es losgehen der straffe
zeitplan wunderbar ein grund stolz zu
sein gute botschaft herzlichen
glückwunsch
[Applaus]
den geistreichsten anteil an dem
gespräch hatte tatsächlich die ente
tatsache ist immer mehr politiker
kneifen wenn zum beispiel politmagazine
interviews wollen und wenden sich
stattdessen lieber direkt an ihr volk
haben sie von trump gelernt
wahrscheinlich fürchte ich werden bald
alle so interviewt oliver welke wie
schaffen sie es wirklich jede woche
immer wieder so genial abzuliefern
das ist eine sehr gute frage oliver ich
denke ich schulde es den fans ganz
ehrlich das ist die beste antwort die
ich jemals gehört habe
vielen dank gerne über die interviews
mit ihnen sind die besten
großartig
ja
schöne den beiden sollte man unbedingt
eine eigene sendung geben an die scheuer
hier ist aber nur ein beispiel von
vielen auch frau kramp karrenbauer aber
neulich ganz begeistert von einem cdu
werkstattgespräch bei dem nur die
eigenen cdu kameras mitlaufen durften
zitat ak wir waren herren der bilder das
ist moderne politische kommunikation
so läuft das heute der praktikant knipst
seine handykamera an und dann wird los
gelabert heute ist weltfrauentag
weltweit hat sich die situation
sicherlich gebessert trotzdem müssen wir
heute feststellen dass es immer noch
frauen gibt die von bildung
ausgeschlossen ist und der praktikant so
klein angelegt haben beim kasten erster
tag ich meine klar medienkritik und
kritik an journalisten ist oft
berechtigt trotzdem haben die medien in
der demokratie eine kontrollfunktion
dass er setzt sich nicht durch lustige
amateurvideos beispiel wir haben eine
bildungsministerin frau kalousek dies in
der realität quasi unsichtbar aber im
netz leider nicht was können sie
besonders gut kochen möhreneintopf mit
was ist ihre größte schwäche schokolade
warum
wer will das wissen hören mit schokolade
du weit vorne beim thema parteien tv und
medien umgehen ist aber natürlich sei es
die afd
ja die haben in berlin sogar einen
eigenen newsroom also ein tv studio mit
20 mitarbeitern aus dem wir bürger mit
genau den fakten versorgt werden die uns
die lügen presse ständig verschweigt ja
du kannst ja den staatsmedien nicht mehr
trauen sich bei der polizei kannst du
trauen
die polizei hat neulich im saarland eine
messerstecher statistik so öffentlich
das heißt diese beamten haben einfach
nur die zahl der messerattacken
ermittelt dem saarländischen fdp
landtagsabgeordneten rudolf müller
reichte das nicht der rechtspopulist
wollte die vornamen der täter wissen das
ergebnis am häufigsten hießen die täter
michael daniel andreas sascha und thomas
wie es ihm geht aber das hätte ich jetzt
nicht gedacht dass doch so viele muslime
andreas und michael eisner die afg ist
stolz auf ihren berliner newsroom und
die fraktionsvorsitzende alles weil hat
in der neuen zürcher zeitung ein klares
ziel formuliert sie sagt die deutschen
sollen irgendwann hfg gucken statt ard
sagte mullah staat zdf endlich
ungefilterte wahrheiten direkt aus dem
afc bunker das wird super
[Musik]
guten abend liebe deutsche zuschauer
ich möchte sie nun mit unserem heutigen
sendeschema vertraut machen
freuen sie sich am vormittag auf unsere
beliebte zur dokumentation die wahrheit
über erdmännchen gorilla & co
ausländische tiere fressen deutschen das
futter weg wir zeigen wie dieser
schäferhund ganz traurig guckt während
es arbeitsscheue löwen aus kenia vorne
und hinten reingeschoben kriegen ein
wahnsinn
danach unser neues afd reportagemagazin
ost frontal 21
wir decken auf die große diese lüge
warum abgase in wirklichkeit total
gesund sind
außer dem skandal im seniorenstift immer
mehr verwirrte opas stehen auf dem flur
und finden ihr zimmer nicht mehr und die
große gender lüge
wer tricks von storch spielt in
wirklichkeit gar nicht führen
wollen sie sich danach auf eine neue
folge wer wird illegaler spenden
millionär das einfachste quiz der welt
die antwort ist immer alice weide oder
jörg merten am vorabend bis romantisch
in unserer daily soap volkssturm der
liebe in der heutigen episode hat die
junge ehrentraut einen schlimmen
verdacht
ronny sag mal warst du beim türken essen
es tut mir leid überhaupt nichts sollte
ja und
[Musik]
wunderbar und dann beginnt auch schon
unser abendprogramm mit afd history die
100 kultigsten weltkriege gefolgt von
spannender unterhaltung beim neuen ard
tatort dem kürzesten tatort aller zeiten
[Musik]
der ausländer was
und zum schluss natürlich schon immer
unsere beliebte talkshow markus lanz
erzählt vom krieg
wer da nicht einschläft der ist schon
tot michael b schreibt auf facebook
wilke du bist der letzte arsch nur große
fresse ich möchte ich mal sehen wenn es
hart auf hart kommt dann schaust du dir
in die hose warte ab ein sprichwort sagt
man trifft sich immer zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 in zwei oder hier auf
youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren